I'd look after we're trying to trade
okay now this a food is plate so I'm
planning to just push push push push
okay we're gonna try to get that palm
pushed up and I think this might have
been a slight in accuracy because we're
gonna push
we take
now we go b5 b6 is coming up so he's
better play Bishop d3 here if that's
something we should retreat that beep on
is just going to be very quick now he
played it ok now we play a three first
to stop this pawn from advancing
before we're trying to get the king in
h4
h5
so we we want to try to push the pong
okay so we take now if things with the
bishop we can push the pawn so he did
not take so we go here
okay now we're trying to win this not
easy
King h4
hmm
not so easy to win should be winning
let's see here
and we managed to win this game with
breakthrough I was pretty hard to win I
think he should have played keep the
bishop on b5 he should have kept the
bishop on b5 and little bit it would
have been very difficult to win he
shouldn't have allow me to play the move
b5 so that was the that was the idea he
should have just kept a bishop early on
here on move number when I played in c3
move 53 Bishop b5 and he might be able
to hold this so let's get to some
questions how do you play against Ben
Oni Banquo I was blundered you need to
study some theory ok so the theory is
very important so you have to study some
theory you know against both systems I
have some ideas definitely I would I
would recommend you to play but if you
study some of my games you'll have an
idea definitely yeah this was a tricky
end game I have to say this opponent was
pretty tough and he managed to break
through so it was very interesting so
let's take a look now what we have here
we have another opponent here we will
get one more game in all right d4
see for
93
I take
thank
now I go III so we have a nice qgd line
here guys qgd okay Bishop d3
now we threaten to take on f6 I don't
think I can
isn't this the YouTube questions then
hey this is YouTube questions right yeah
this is YouTube questions guys yes I can
read it mm-hmm yes I can read your
questions and absolutely
why not Red Bull with normal sugar I
don't know I just grabbed this one this
felt like I need a little energy so this
page for that previous game was pretty
tough one guys it was not easy to break
through okay 986 threatening night so I
play a three stopping night before
business
castle
see for Bishop f5
quintics who is the best player you have
played ever magnus carlsen probably yep
Magnus Carlsen all right this guy
blundered the peace guys oops
and now dropping the peace huh LP deal
loose peace drop-off only seven guys so
we got this one I think taking this one
now and we are in good shape for a draw
you gotta be kidding me and I was a joke
big fan from Bangladesh thank you thank
you
it's my L can you show more French
defence games absolutely absolutely
I will be doing more stuff I just the
schedule has been really busy guys a lot
going on tournaments coming up when we
play a little bit more hopefully get up
my rating a little bit higher and
absolutely you're gonna see me play make
sure you watch my tournament games and
I'm sure you're gonna see some French
defence next tournament I'll be playing
in it's gonna be the one in ILO men feed
a ground Swiss tournament guys make sure
you watch that one and I think you will
cow
yep all right okay Denny if people log
in how they can find this out there only
chess is there are anything they need to
just follow st. Louis chess club or okay
here can you come for a sec yeah
as the can you tell this person how to
find it or is there a boat oh yeah they
tried to my students they want to watch
it they're like I told them leeches
right yeah yeah yeah
leeches not work and yeah they're trying
to find okay guys so excellent so all
right let's see who we got here next all
right we got wait five minutes I didn't
click on this one five minutes okay long
game guys let's play three plus two okay
next time thank you thank you mm-hmm all
right
a four is six we got the French this was
a long game I didn't see three plus 2
would be the favorable time control guys
so we can get more people in okay well
ding would beat but being lost today
guys he somehow he lost today in Rajab
Oh equalized you know the match
definitely yeah I think being the dink
has a chance yeah
well let's see here we got this okay
let's play this way so that's a good
question from Danielle Matson how do you
feel about being so close to win the US
Championship but we didn't manage to
clinch it in the end well tough tough
tough tough I
I was so close guys I don't know if you
know the whole history the very first
u.s. Championship I played in 2003 I got
the wild-card I was 19 years old you
know people who followed will remember
this story I was playing Charbel off in
the last round
two pounds up probably winning position
all I had to do win the game
and I will be the US Champion in my
first try in a first attempt in 2003 I
got you know very excited 19 years old
and I just made a mistake and lost the
game so that was a tough one
then I was very close on few occasions
probably very close in 2014 to win it
I was basically you know one move away
from winning the US Champion 2014
against Alex landed one again last round
got an overwhelming position just have
to find this move and probably just win
the game in the championship and then I
went into playoffs I won the first
playoff against Alex but they lost to
come ski that was 2014 guys then the end
came 2017 you remember I had a great run
I won the game against Fabiano Caruana
and I was leading but last round tough
loss against Socorro stops I've had
three three close calls three three
close calls to win a US Championship but
[Music]
didn't quite work so we'll see now it's
it's so obviously disappointing but you
know you just got to look forward to it
and hopefully I can do it you know I
think just I still have a chance I know
the competition is getting tougher and
tougher but
it's all about playing your best chess
if you play your best chest throughout
those you know 11 games you have a
chance I think any of the players have a
chance mm-hmm
now I Castle
Queen f6
well well I was 17 in the first nineteen
in the first try but that was two years
ago I was very close I really had a good
chance two years ago and 2014 probably
was very close I think I have a personal
leaches account yeah I set it up but I
haven't got around playing much I really
enjoy the site and I think it's great a
lot of good feedback about it and a lot
of people enjoying it you know I do have
I think it's something like GMO Cobian I
know I set it up and I mentioned that
I'm available for lessons there or
something but these days I'm just quite
busy guys with the private lessons and
other a lot of chess related work that I
do here in st. Louis so I don't get to
play that much but I always enjoy
playing yeah I think this is not an easy
position for me to win ok this was maybe
a mistake to take the bishop I feel like
you should have probably played a four
and try to play for b5 at some point I
feel like this should be okay but yeah
III didn't see that this was a five plus
three so we want to make sure we play
shorter games guys
okay
okay I play just six mm-hmm
are we putting some pressure
now putting pressure mm-hmm
okay can I just take all c5 here guys
can I just take that free pawn here
question alright
taking that pawn
all right let's go here Roxy three okay
by the way we met at the Nationals you
were very nice it was awesome to meet
you
awesome nice meeting you too semi what
player would have the best chance to
take crown from mock now I feel like
dink has a good chance guys I really
think dink has has a shot you know
it's not gonna be easy but he has a
chance so we we have a pretty good
position here
[Applause]
yeah we got some good pressure guys we
got a extra pawn as well you know so I
probably played d4 next move let's see
here Levon Aronian once said magnus is
copying exactly what Fisher did waiting
he meant by that I don't know I'm not
sure what my friend LaVon meant you know
referring to Carlsen
I mean copying I don't know I think it's
different you know magnus is different
he's you know I mean it's very very
clear that you know they were very he
was they're both very talented do you
think chess players should work out
absolutely you gotta work out if you
don't work out these days I don't think
you're gonna last a chance to win a big
tournament you can just gonna get so
tired and you're gonna run out of energy
you gotta work out all the top players
work out some do weights some do cardio
Magnus does I think both he enjoys doing
sports a little bit more than I think
the weights and everything but yeah he's
you got a workout I mean I I try to work
out feel better feel feel feel really
good when I'm playing chess so you have
to be in good shape guys I mean it's
it's it's you have to import important
to to work out what makes things so good
does he have a different style of
playing a Dinks is just what he's very
versatile player he when he gets a good
position what he is amazing amazing ad
he just he can convert he can really
convert as good positions so that's
that's what makes him really really good
steaks rook takes I played b6 just to
stop his pawn from moving I mean
position is winning here I just went
ahead put a little bit more cautiously
here did he just resign yes it is done
yeah guys if you're sending a challenge
just make sure it's three plus two
because we we get a lot of people
waiting I want to get as many people to
play as possible so and yeah you can you
know send me your questions and comments
didn't loss today yes why a wonderful
variation as win over is so rare at the
top level well because I think according
to the current computers there are some
problems in a validation and it's just
difficult to to place to equalize yeah
so again once again guys I see a couple
of five minutes challenges we really
want to stick with a three plus two time
control and see if we get so let's let's
try to see if we can get a French going
here so d5 okay see fire we got this
Bishop e3 is gaining some popularity
lately you know so we take take
all right now we're gonna get this
knight on d5
okay take I took the power because I
want to get my bishop out maybe quintics
was better but that's okay
create
all right let's see here Bishop Knight
retreat let's get that night on a5 see
what's going on here let's see if we
have some good question how to face the
strong opponents psychologically well
just be ready to order for a fight you
know you have to be ready to play and
you play you know when the game starts
you just followed what the moves are you
know you forget about who you playing
just opponent makes a move you try to
find the best move mm-hmm interesting
first I played that's quite a nice
progress Daniel
medicine you made in three years 18:35
fede and your first year was inspired by
me well I appreciate that I'm glad
you're doing so well
gaining 1835 that's that's great music
guitar are the mtv cameras still
following you you know not anymore guys
that was that was a long time ago I was
on MTV true life documentary so that was
that was a lot of fun you know being on
cameras but that was just a long time
ago and you know it was pretty cool
experience you got interested in chess
when you saw that okay yeah that's yeah
it was really cool experience first I
wasn't so sure about it that was like
it's gonna take some of my time and I
was like but yeah then I'm glad I did it
because it was really nice experience
and it helped I think a little bit
popularize chess to find out you know so
people can see all over the world
actually that would that documentary was
all over the world I had people
messaging me from Colombia from Armenia
you know like a lot of my friends from
everywhere it was it was even not just
the US a lot of people said it was all
over the world guys there was in 2008 I
want to say okay what are we doing here
or is this Quinn looks kind of funny
they're not let's attack it this Quinn
is gonna get attacked now let's see if
we can do something about it
are we are we trapping the Queen guys
what is the Queen going after g5 here am
I missing something here
are we missing something let's see let's
see here
I think this Queen is trapped here guys
that's why you have to play the move h3
you know to stop Bishop c4 you are let's
see well guys please send your challenge
we got a lot of people in line so
hopefully we could get to you let's see
well I don't know yeah it's the question
is it sees how many times I played
Magnus and overall score well I only
played him twice that's why it's easy to
remember
well one time it was one time he was a
pro pro chess League protesting finals
and I was just at a mini game and I was
a really good game it was very close
game and I he won on time at the end and
it was better so and the second time
I've been in world blitz championship
actually that one I missed the wind guys
I had a nice tactic against him and I
missed it to win the peace and the game
here so I only played him twice so so to
experience is playing Magnus so we won
the game guys look at that Queen shrub
that's why you gotta get the Queen to a
safety mm-hmm let's see solid opening
what was the business but difficulty
memorising yeah it's not about
memorizing your opening so much it's
about understanding guys you want to try
to understand your openings okay when
I'm teaching my students I put the
accent on helping them to yeah yeah it's
it's important to that you get
comfortable okay so let's with your
positions understanding the moves okay
all right let's see
absolutely all the gyms have favorite
openings okay
Booker I'm Kate chess coach Verona
Cobian please make a video every week
well guys yes that that's something
maybe in the future I will do it no I
might do something like that and to a
post that might be an idea okay I'm
gonna see here all right let's get one
more game in here Tolly Porter's let's
see here d4
how can we play there's a link here so
you can just click on that link ice and
you will be in the cube okay
I take
I go Bishop g5
Quincy to
Bishop d3 is coming up
okay this tree farm I'm not sure guys it
weakens the position well how to improve
your chest when you knew it when you
knew it just so many things you can do
to improve you know you know when you
knew there's so many things you can
study openings middlegame
end games go over your fundamentals
there are so many things you can really
do to improve okay it's there for so
have some fun and play lawn castle guys
let's move this King to the safety and
now we got some 95 ideas coming up as
well
some nice trickery casino with 95 let's
see rooks see Juan comes in cooking that
95
and look at this beautiful tactic you
overlooked guys beautiful look at that
night b5 we prepped it and prepped it
enough and he didn't see it he thought
we were just doubling up
he just didn't see it and now this move
ends the game here guys block is losing
material and finito finito
winning exchange winning upon and when
we are ahead we just trade right so
remember that guys when you're ahead you
always just trade
yeah
so that take
and once again we aware ahead we trade
right guys yep another wind guys this
was nice
okay
you get through the queue faster if you
just play simultaneous I'm oh alright
let's see here we got a lot of people in
line so we're gonna get a couple of more
games in guys we got 31 people still
waiting so let's see here alright let's
see here
yeah really we don't really want to find
many games that will take too long guys
because you know if we just play five
minigames not just bit too long okay so
let's get this in go ahead
okay
okay
just accept another game while you
already planed how's that gonna work you
play two games at the same time I don't
know guys I'm not sure about that we
play six okay we can take on d4 and play
maybe okay he took first so then we play
some isolated pawns yeah Parrish ISO
Lamas
castle
Oh Kate
okay have you played GM Ben Feingold I
think I might have played Ben once or
twice once didn't both times in the u.s.
yeah one draw I think I played Ben three
times total so we drew the first time we
played that's when I met him 2005 I
think we drew we drew and I remember Ben
got is GM norm there which was you know
he was working on it so it was it was a
good good good time for him
Chicago so he gotta Jam them there then
we played in one of the US Championship
in 2008 2007 in Tulsa Oklahoma
I want that game I was blocked and then
I was blocked again one time with him in
u.s. championship here in st. Louis and
I think he was playing here
he had the wild card at the year and I
played Ben and I withdrew that was just
the nimzo-indian yeah I accept
challenges whoever is in the queue so no
problem I'll be happy to play any GM's
also if they want to challenge me there
is no restriction okay lay the people
okay we play everybody guys do I
challenge the LM since Lewis I believe
so yes heavy plate Yasser say the one
I've played yeah Cyril so yes I believe
only once I played him actually in a
tournament game and that was when he
came back after retirement in 2012 the
answer came back and we played in the
first round of the US Championship and I
was white and I was like a Queen's gonna
be the client type of position but I got
a good position and I won I won with
white so 2012 US Championship you guys
can check that out check out that game
if you want it was a pretty good
positional game it's like an endgame
grind that's the only time we play with
yes sir
all right guys let's plant this
Oh f6
okay let's get that pawn on e4 guys I
have an interesting idea I might suck my
exchange on v3 no like a petrol C on
style you know like petrosyan exchange
sacrifice it was Shawn branch the branch
name Petrosyan game you remember that
game we put that rook on v3
what was the purpose of age six my
opponent resigned that is interesting
why did he resign guys I don't know I
have no idea why I resigned I mean I'm
better but the screen on d2 is misplaced
the night should be only - do I ever
study game so bent Larsen I mean I'm
came across this games I
yeah I have studied some but I never
particularly went and study his games
particularly I studied a lot of karpov
games I studied a lot of Karpov and
petrosyan games guys okay please make a
video and you're playing chess against
like Hikaru Nakamura well I have video
against Sakura Nakamura I made it was
you know I have a video that I won the
game and I think I have a video that I
lost the game so this is a great concept
of live games you guess the next move
and then compare with GM's your opponent
resigned victor says you because sacking
idea you think he listened that I was
gonna sack on v3 and resigned can you
play with Henson or a mom best of 10
games on I mean I'm there my friends
I'll be happy to play them yeah at some
point maybe we'll have a little match
you know it every can a mom yeah I think
I'll be fun yes of course we have a
greetings in Russia of course I
understand everything I read everything
in Russian and I can speak Russian very
fluently so absolutely you can type in
Russian and I'll be you know happy to
answer your questions
absolutely okay let's see here guys we
got about half an hour left
let's get couple of we got 41 people in
a queue and again this wasn't even like
plant damage this stream today this was
like kind of a last minute thing you
know but we're getting some good numbers
here guys but make sure tomorrow tune in
tomorrow at 3 o'clock Central Time we're
gonna try to break the all-time record
tomorrow ok
of all the people watching us tomorrow
is the regular time that we do the
stream with from the Chess Club account
so so tune in tomorrow guys at 3 o'clock
we're gonna have some fun and play some
games and and I think it's a lost game
over the World Cup tomorrow so maybe
we'll have a World Cup champion we can
talk about that a little bit being is
white maybe he can seal the deal you
know with white against right job of so
we'll see okay we got another qgd here
we got a Dario mm rated opponent Dario
playing us
so see so here Picasso let's see here
what my opponent is going to do
my idea is to play f3 let's see some
games which games did I study karpov
games guys Karpov petrosyan games a lot
what is the point of remembering games I
mean not remembering so much it's
understanding the ideas you learn from
the best I like the techniques you know
how they you know put their pieces you
know absolutely you it's not so much
about memory no not so much about
memorizing it but seeing what they did
and understanding some games versus
Jinger Jim would be awesome too by the
way may you play the black line black
line opening by the way you play the
black line what's which one is the black
line guys not for me to be that opening
supernova yeah around three o'clock
we're gonna start all right I mean
languages I know I am
you know fluent in Russian Armenian in
English and I can understand and speak
some Spanish as well I spent a lot of
time in South and South and Central
America playing tournaments and you know
there are many friends from there I
enjoy the Spanish language and culture
so I have many friends there
so really enjoy you know I would love to
learn Spanish fluently that's you know
my little bucket list at some point to
have a little bit you know but to learn
fluently language you you have to have
an it for it you know I have an it for
it or leave in a country then then I
think you will learn quickly you know
language so probably Spanish would be
that's what I would like to learn and be
fluent in it mm-hmm you're gonna
challenge me tomorrow yeah if you
haven't challenged me today guys you're
probably not gonna be able to get a game
I mean welcome to hang out and watch you
know but we got a lot of people in the
queue we got the thirty people still in
a queue here so let's see here let's see
bar do you coach yes that's where I'm
due mostly guys I coach a lot this days
I still play
absolutely approximate Emil as the world
chess champion well I don't know that's
a tough question I mean that's a really
tough question I mean if we will have
that or not it's time will only tell
guys we have some very strong female
players but world championship that's
that's that's different level okay I'm
not sure what's your favorite opening
for black what's your favorite opening
for black French I guess you probably
eyes probably know I play the French
French is good I like the nimzo-indian
let's see here
okay now what are we doing here okay
this opponent is doing some stuff here
let's try to feel like we should do
something here but I don't know what
let's go here first preparing a for
okay let's see here we got some light
squirter issues upon until we have a
crew
yeah tres is getting very young we have
a question in Russian from our 17 year
old chess is getting very young so to be
professional player you have to start
very young and try to become a
grandmaster early if you started late
you might be tough you know to to have
chess as a career
you know because you really have to at
least become a grandmaster to to do
chess professionally in my opinion
94 we take we trade now we go for a
pleasant endgame guy see a slightly
Pleasant okay not a huge advantage but
slightly Pleasant okay Pleasant a let's
see here
greetings from our friends in Mexico yes
many call friends always enjoy visiting
Mexico many times I've played there
tournaments great place great food habla
espanol
Paquito see now we go here attacking h4
could you recommend a book on 2300 level
I mean book on what I mean there are
there many books
I mean book on which will be more
specific we need book on what
specifically you you're working on it
now there are books out there but it
will really help if you tell me what
earlier the game is trying to improve a
lot of people say Geary is you know do
agree now here is great guys gear is
yeah is yeah you cannot be overrated and
be number four in the world okay that's
just not possible
so I mean you you must be good to be at
our level so there there is no such a
thing of anybody being overrated at that
level the competition is just fierce
okay yeah there is this competition is
very very fierce and you're not gonna
survive there if you're not a taut
string you're just simply not gonna
survive okay so I don't believe in
anybody being overrated and being there
that they don't belong that's I don't
think that's so yeah I lost my advantage
here guys I just kind of played bit too
casually here and let my opponent
but he's got no time just the problem is
when you got no time even if the
position is equal you're probably going
to lose because of the time okay
you put this guy here we're gonna put
this guy here and now we're gonna say
give me the pawn are you gonna say give
me the pesca pashka means pawn and
russian you can attack the pesckow on d5
and we're gonna break it and he dropped
a rock see how that works guys you put
pressure pressure on the opponent and
win a time trouble they're gonna
collapse
you put problems in front of the
opponents gonna be very difficult to
solve those problems alright let's see
here guys somehow
how long Vichy will be which is great
which is great he will you know still be
there at the very top is a fantastic
player you know heels it's hard to say
how long he'll be a top 10 player but he
perfect you know he's playing excellent
chess I always root for Vichy it's a
good friend are you coming to India to
play in yeah I don't travel too much
guys these days to play in tournaments I
mean I only just trouble if it's some
really really big tournament okay gotcha
do we just and now or play more games
okay okay gotcha okay guys we are yeah
I'm gonna go over your question so we're
not gonna do more games I think because
we have some issues you know like a
signal or signal reconnecting some
Internet issues guys so we might have to
end a little bit earlier today let's see
play somewhere stronger I'm happy to
play anybody guys just as long as
they're in the queue I'll be happy to
play anybody absolutely and so tomorrow
guys make sure you tune in okay
three o'clock Central Time and we'll
have a great time we'll play some more
games okay so tomorrow three o'clock
we'll be here and Tuli chess playing
chess and we'll we'll talk more if you
have some good questions prepared them
for tomorrow okay prepare them and you
can ask me tomorrow okay okay sorry so
finish finishing a little bit earlier
today but just we got some connection
issues so we're gonna try to work that
out and make it make it work for
tomorrow okay
so we have perfect stream tomorrow all
right guys see you tomorrow at 3 o'clock
you